I'd like to make a comment about the
more general thing though this question
of what was the phrase that was used for
the naive view of reality manifest image
yeah whether that is something that
makes sense is permissible to us it
seems to me it obviously is in our
everyday life I mean we all agree that
Romney and Barack Obama are real than
the Santa Claus is not real we use it as
a useful phrase and it would be hard to
live without this this meaning of
reality and sin and you know it isn't
because we deny that scent well maybe
it's because we deny that Santa Claus is
the post-development tree particles but
that's not the way we really think about
it we we just recognize it as a mess I
think the question is why should we not
use this kind of principle philistinism
refusing to think deeply but just using
real the way we use other terms in our
everyday life why we shouldn't do that
in physics or science also well is there
really a philosophical discontinuity
between everyday life the kind of
reasoning we do in everyday life and
science which makes this this naive view
of reality impermissible in one whereas
it's useful in the other free will is a
classic example of where we have a
feeling of agency on the manifest level
but in reality we don't and if you're in
your again going beyond the I mean we
can argue about that I I think we do
I think freewill is real but that's for
another session but everyone in this
room has used the word
real
I'm reflecting on philosophical
unsophisticated way and I don't see any
reason for barring its use in Sciences
also I mean we i have professor at
Cornell 1i Ossipee course max black
hahaha
said that whenever he has asked the
question whether something is real he
always gives the same answer the answer
is yes but but really different ways and
that is something want them going do I
think temperature is real I think
protons are real a real in slightly
different ways I think the Constitution
of the United States is real and I think
this newspaper is real and they're also
real in different ways and that's
interesting to explore that but we
shouldn't limit the use of the word real
to things which are real and only one
narrow sense
you